alright I think a lot of you are still
mad at me and I gotta say I feel
vulnerable especially coming in today
after being out yesterday let's just say
apparently I was not missed Casey and
New Orleans writes so they finally fired
your fat ass really
Alexis via Time Warner the chubby chumps
been chopped do you pee no more negative
Trump bashing from this broadcast fake
with the fake hair and the fat neck and
the time off to atone for your sins and
maybe eat a salad hurtful Alexis as I
told you before the camera adds 50
pounds I know a number of people have
met me in person would tell you
otherwise but I don't like you to
believe that tkv eh well I dunno out
only a day after calling out our
president and mr. nevertrump er is
Nevermore and Karma's something Tony
yeah because
Tubby's still here so i can imagine some
of you are bit disappointed but really
all because of this no they say you have
to keep your friends close and your
enemies closer but that doesn't mean
criticize your friends and give your
enemies cover mr. president that doesn't
mean you need to constantly praise us
but on foreign soil at least you might
consider praising our enemies less you
say you want to drain the swamp then may
I suggest you stop throwing the mud or
at least save it for leaders who are
dirty and not those who simply deserve
better for having the temerity of
pointing it out Tony in Rochester New
York so we even after the president
explains his error
you're still not buying it lunk head no
I'm not Tony because with Vladimir Putin
he was very very clear my people came to
me dan coates came to me and some others
they said they think it's Russia I have
president putin he just said it's not
Russia I will say this I don't see any
reason why it would be I have great
confidence in my intelligence people but
I will tell you that President Putin was
extremely strong and powerful in his
denial today you see that's what struck
me not one word all those words all the
fawning but I guess it was my immediate
reaction fbn which we don't get you you
should demand that prompted the real
bridge this is the time the place for
the president to look
and squarely in the eye and said you
will be punished for what you did in
2016 and don't ever think about doing
that again but he didn't and that made
it disgusting that's what made his
performance disgusting I'm sorry just
the only way I feel it's not a right or
left thing to be it's just wrong like US
President on foreign Sall talking to our
biggest enemy or adversary or competitor
right I don't know how we define them
these days is essentially letting the
guy get away with this and not even you
know offering a mild a mild criticism
that sets us back a lot GPS beat see you
know what's disgusting Kedah don't you
tender via Yahoo look up disgusting of
the dictionary there is a picture of you
I did look it up in the dictionary in
there and there is no such picture that
is fake news
Kevin emails disgusting is watching you
talk disgusting is watching you live and
by the way disgusting is watching a guy
who's so fat here we go again
the only reason some of his viewers
stick around is to see him croak on live
TV really PS this is the shocker I'm
disgusted with you oh really Kevin
I couldn't tell Amy via Twitter how
quickly your base turns on you're
actually speaking the truth it's what I
deal with Amy it's what I deal with
Judith to be a Verizon thank God there
are a few honorable and honest people on
fbn but you are not among them you are
disgusting
not that's a bit drunk you know I
thought that was shaping up to be a
compliment a positive even apparently
not applied via att.net are you on a
suicide mission fatso here we go again
who do you think butters all that bread
you stacked on your Fox plate let me
look at it I have no idea
it's Trump chump now pack up your
ring-dings and leave Steve I see what
you kind of do in here unless you're
going for the rhyming thing it's Neil
then in that case it's very snide Clyde
but you did hurt my feelings especially
with the jump thing that that thing
sadly I've gotten used to that I don't
know Omar via MSN you're a mess to look
at an even bigger mess to hear you
remind me
that character that bastard in Austin
Powers but he was funny
you're just gross well Omar then you did
not love that movie
Don in Miami so down Lynn no you settle
down but thanks for calling me Celine
Carol on Facebook I used to really like
Cavuto but he's been infected with
libera Listeria diarrhea of the jawbone
as well as the other end I see Nancy
writes Cavuto you're a nevertrump ER and
your commentary proved it beyond the
doubt stick to business news in other
words shut up already you shut up
already
Terry writes Thank You Neil Cavuto
chillin bravery by telling the truth
about Trump it was an amazing common
sense
I tried anyway Terry in Georgia Kabuto
you are disgusting little twerp who's
sarcastic smug well know-it-all attitude
is an absolute turn off my wife tried to
tell me some time ago that you were a
slimy little weasel and now I fully
agree with her whatever I can do to help
your marriage but sorry to hear that but
do do appreciate the little comments oh
that was very big of you Jim in Florida
Neil I'm finished with you no Jim I'm
finished with you Ricky Mills you're an
idiot no wonder I quit watching you oh
really
then how would you know what I just said
dawn I don't know it's childish dawn in
Oregon Neil why should anybody believe
our intelligence officers or agencies
over Vladimir Putin because Donald Trump
did and now I think says he does Alex
via Gmail what the hell do you know
about dignity the fact that you have a
network TV show is a testament of the
fact that America is run by well
inferior compromised individuals looking
forward to hearing the skeletons in your
closet rot in hell I'm not gonna say
that I don't think I'm giving you a
Nielsen box just for that and Brad via
Gmail Neil you are a big-headed [ __ ]
and you my friend are a small-minded one
Paul via Gmail Trump should have been
more upfront with people now I can see
being polite on on his first official
meeting but he gave away the farm John
Williamsburg Virginia was the president
forceful enough in telling Putin that
Russia meddled in our elections and a
majority of the media and Americans say
no well that's all I'm saying here guys
I understand the need to be friendly but
as Ronald Reagan has shown that doesn't
mean you still can't be forceful Anthony
in Philadelphia curious how you love to
read but you don't love to balance out
that rent with guests who might disagree
well funny Anthony then you must have
missed this particular guest on the same
show do you think the president through
America under the bus I think we need to
take a step back and ask ourselves is a
good to have conversation with your
adversaries is it good to have open
lines of communications with Russia
Marcy the Gmail thank you for bringing
in Rand Paul to talk about the Helsinki
summit Senator Paul is a voice of reason
buddy the SBC I used to give you a break
because of your health issues cancer M s
that hard thing or whatever else God is
punishing you with for the moment but
not now now I just want you gun and if
that means dead so be it never Trump
errs must never be allowed to infect our
world sorry I hope you understood well
of course she won't be dead I understand
mikail emails comrade Kabuto three words
get over yourself you're not there
you're not balanced you're not handsome
in fact you're not even passingly human
so save the Trump judgments for those
qualified to make them the only reason
I'm not saying more it's somewhat
totally you've had a lot of health
issues so really some health issues end
I don't want to be the one responsible
for a drug overdose but that doesn't
mean I can't hope right keep hoping the
call I want you to listen to what you
just said because it was a lot more than
three words and speaking of Arlene and
Waterbury Connecticut writes keep
dreaming about that Trump interview you
will never get now good at oh it is so
sad to watch a grown man play out his
petty differences with the president the
United States and all because nothing to
do with you the president wants nothing
to do with you next time on ETS night
sleep well Arlene I I have said it
before I will say it again people know
leave this but I have zero zilch not a
interest in interviewing the president
now many had and they've done a great
job he always makes news with each and
every one I have zero interest in adding
my name to the list I'm pretty sure no
one at the White House is losing sleep
over this but it's just how I feel and I
just thought again I should let you know
besides it leaves more time for
apparently eating anyway I am NOT trying
to curry favor or disfavor with anyone
just reporting the news for everyone
which is my way of saying you're welcome
America even though some of you are
blocking see you tomorrow